hey everyone welcome to led live on this
episode we want to ask you guys
what is the gospel to you find out on
this episode of
led live
light exposing darkness welcome back
everybody to another episode we just
thank you so much for continuing to
watch and subscribe we want to thank our
patrons you guys are so faithful
and loyal you guys are helping support
this show and make it happen
every week so we want to thank you and
um
you know we're just so blessed by the
comments you give us
and all the um all the sharing that you
do with your friends and neighbors
we're excited because i'm really excited
because you know on this show
we see people interacting with us
through email
through social media or whatnot they're
not christian
some of them are atheists some of them
are agnostic some of them are from you
know
all different walks of life and we're
excited about that we like to dialogue
with the broader community so we thank
you guys for watching and engaging with
us
even though you don't see eye to eye
with us on every single point
okay so second coming i haven't told you
guys hardly squat about this
so this is going to be interesting i was
looking around
on some entertainment websites recently
and i came across
this article and it was about a comic
book it's like okay
what intrigued me was the title and you
can see it here it says second coming
jesus and sunstar return and only
begotten son
you don't see jesus in a comic book
website heading too often so
you know let's see what this is about i
want to get into this so we're going to
take a look at that today
[Music]
hey youtube why does god allow suffering
why would an all-loving god allow pain
and suffering
let me break it down to you in five
minutes or less
[Music]
so
this comic book that we're going to be
looking at is written by a guy named
mark
russell he's a writer he likes to
reimagine different
works in a new and interesting way he's
written a number of comic books
and other things he wrote
a new rendition of the flintstones for
dc you can see there it's he seems
particularly interested in
social satire okay i like a fred's old
muscular
dude and if you could look closely
um one of the characters she has a book
about
cannibalism i think it's his daughter
and i forget what is her name pebbles
yeah
yeah pebbles has a book about
cannibalism on her so this is like
israel different
it's probably like she's like a
millennial or something yeah i guess
into the weird stuff anyway anyway he he
he likes to uh you know see what's going
on in the world and reflect that
in his writing style and then you know
he's not an illustrator because other
people illustrate
and uh he likes to teach a particular
lesson through
satire so hollywood reporter had this
title the second coming writer
defends controversial comic with an
author's note so the original article
that caught my eye was
they're actually doing a follow-up
series to this second coming comic book
okay so we're going to go through the
first one because the follow-up
obviously hasn't been released yet
and we're going to see what is so
controversial about this
okay so just so i get this straight this
is a comic book that is satire so it's
meant to be funny
it's not meant to be serious but what
they're doing is they're they're trying
to take a
you know a topic like religion or
whatever like that and then they just
kind of throw
everything in there so he's gonna give
you his perspective
right right so well i just want to
explore what that is with you guys and
i'm not against like
reimagining anything i mean if you can
figure out a really cool way to retell
the gospel and it doesn't
you know diminish it in any kind of way
and it just tells it in like a future
setting or something i think that's cool
you know kind of updating
and you it's like another parable you
know jesus told the gospel using stories
so we're not against that right yeah no
not against that where i draw the line
is
if you're absolutely just making fun of
it putting it in a bad light
twisting the truth because yes maybe
there's
a lot of people that are going to walk
away being like hey this is a joke but
there's
some people whether it be one or two
that's too many
that are gonna walk away with it with
like you know what dude christianity is
a joke
so he actually got a lot of heat from
this um
from christians and uh
they were gonna publish it originally i
think with vertigo
but they got enough slack that they
decided to go with another independent
publisher
so yeah it's it's got some interesting
ideas in here and for
you know i guess for what it's worth as
i look at this and i say you know
this is how other people think and so if
i'm going to interact with the world
around me i need to stand
understand how other people view the
gospel or view the second coming or view
jesus so i know how to interact with
them as well
so i'll see where this goes this is what
he said
in one of the big bold prints at the top
for better or worse
this is my blasphemy oh okay
and we'll get into what that means later
on down the line but it is
kind of uh sounds like he's announcing
an interesting way
it's going to be blasphemous right yeah
funny how people though
when they're doing something that they
know they shouldn't recognize that
yeah right you know what i mean like
he's like even to just make a statement
like that
yeah you i i don't know if you're
talking about any other religion
buddhism
muslim whatever like you would not make
a statement like that like this is i'm a
heretic
i don't like ice cream yeah i know it's
a you know yeah it's a bad thing to say
but you know it's actually really
interesting that you said that because i
want to do
a patreon post show that
is about mark russell in a different
work that he did
it's called god is disappointed in you
and
it's his basically short version
summarizing the bible oh wow okay and in
there
he has some comments about other
religions so if you think that would
interest you
make sure you check out the post show
for this god is disappointed in you okay
all right so i need to give you guys a
little bit of a backstory so you can see
where this thing is going where it's
coming from where it's headed
and uh you know just so you know this
could be
really offensive to some people so
i apologize if it's offensive to you
it's somebody else's work
it's not that this is our viewpoint
and we're just exploring this i think a
lot of the stuff we've played on this
channel
is very offensive to many christians
yeah morning morning
i mean yeah so this is a comic book
strip
this is from volume one that he did and
there's a there's a
scene with mary magdalene she's buried
up to her neck and
rocks or some some light i'm guessing
it's mary magdalene
says but the law didn't make them better
people and then it says this adulteress
is condemned to death by stony
and it says it just made them feel
better about the lack of mercy
and then she's crying out please don't i
beg you okay
well as it moves to the next strip here
is a picture of
jesus and it looks like god is rising up
from something you see all these
candlesticks on the screen
says there has to be another way to help
them
referring to the people on earth not to
just
escape punishment but to actually become
better people
to give them what they need to somehow
lead them back to the garden of eden
sounds like we're tracking right and
then jesus looks up and he questions
he's like dad you're back
go to the next section here it says
um you know it's got god he's looking
down at some
shepherds and he's calling them jerks
and then here's this monologue with god
he says i am through with these people
never should have mixed them with
monkeys from now on
they're on their own and he's pouring
himself a drink
yeah i guess here's where the uh satire
yeah
the theologians kind of yeah get
something
showing that god's an alcoholic yeah so
god is just this
old grumpy alcoholic dude and he's
angry which is a lot like the show you
covered that one time what was that
show the only one that we've actually
gotten totally taken away from
youtube the one with the angel thingy oh
the good
place the good place yeah so if you've
never seen the good place
yeah episode and you won't see it on
youtube you have to go to our patreon
it's there and if you have trouble we
can find another way to get it to you
you can you can see it but i think it's
for free on patreon you can watch it
there
only episode that was completely taken
down we could not
get it on youtube so that alone should
make it really interesting to you
yeah i thought there was another one
that you did probably
man keith is hitting them it'll probably
be this one next controversial ones um
have you ever run into people that kind
of view god
that way yeah oh yeah they don't
understand him and i think that that is
what the devil's main method of
confusion
throughout the history i mean we know
that jesus had to come
and show people the proper picture of
god right
it had so been darkened that they were
walking around going wow you're
paralyzed what sin did you do you know
what i mean like not thinking like hey
we're broken
and we've you know we this could be
easily a genetic
you know foul fallacy or whatever you
know
and so um yeah and he was always trying
to
he always had to redirect people's
mindsets like
you guys are a bunch of hypocrites just
you know
rigidly making up all these laws and
trying to do it perfectly but you have
you know you're honoring me with your
lips but your hearts are far from me
so he was always having to point people
the right way
because they were either this way or
that way you ever heard
god of the old testament god of the new
testament yeah right as if
you know they're different they're not
on the same page
one is harsh and mean the other one is
kind and gentle yeah i think you see a
little bit of that as this is
taking shape so here they are it says so
you're just going to leave them down
there this is jesus making a question
god says well i did try drowning them he
takes a
drink and then he says jesus is is
looking down and he says can i give it a
shot
help them in my own way so
so here's problem number one that i have
with that statement
obviously is i tried to drown them no
god tried to save you
you know i mean like like he was all
about giving you
a hundred and twenty years of explaining
to the people
listen you have derailed your faith
in god and there's a you know thing
that's coming
their hearts are only wicked continually
what sane person would want a world like
that to exist where everybody's killing
each other
molesting each other raping murder you
don't want that
so you say look i have a different way
for you get on the ark i'm gonna restart
this thing and it can be a great place
so because it's satire i i kind of like
cut him
a little bit of slack here because i'm
like okay i'm not
a hundred percent sure is he making fun
of christians who believe this way
because obviously
it's not right or is he just
reflecting society i almost think that
if that's not clear
crystal clear you leave for the viewer
to sort of like
latch onto that and identify with it you
know what i mean so somebody else is
like slamming god yeah he's just up
there just drinking and
he doesn't care about us you people are
going to identify with that because
that's what you do with art right
you you watch those pieces or you read
those
pieces or whatever because you find some
common thing that you like about that
so i i think it alarms me to put
something out there like that and i
would question his motives
if he really was like no god's really a
loving nice guy it's like why would you
make something like this then
well we'll see where this goes says
want to try your hand at the family
business huh this is god talking to him
he said well why not and jesus says
thanks dad i won't let you down and of
course if you could see in the
background
it's like almost like a full bar it's
got the ice
you know the wall is full of bottles of
alcohol and
you know it's making it like that god
just ran out of options you know and
then jesus is like hey let me give it a
shot
but we know that from the beginning god
had this plan that he was gonna he was
gonna send his son it wasn't just some
like
wait i got an idea god you know makes it
look like god gave up
yeah let's go to the next section he
says thanks dad i won't let you down
and he says good for you boy show them
who they're messing with
that's right son of god coming through
and i had to actually
white out some of the words that they
used in the
comic here expletives so anyway
so that's part of the back story so here
here it continues and he says uh tumteed
um
let's see how the boy is doing ha ha
uh give him you know give him hell son
and then he shows a pain where god's
reacting to this and he says
wait they're arresting him like he's
really surprised right
of course we know god is not surprised
by anything right
and then he goes in the next pain it
says you're just letting them put you
on trial what are you an idiot
what's that cross for and then
you see god is enraged he's yelling out
what and then he's like cheese and
crackers and throws down his drink
and he's really upset about the fact
that
jesus is dying on the cross
it also makes it appear as if
it wasn't a cohesive plan together for
the plan of salvation
you know i mean this was set in motion
before the foundation of the world right
and
and you know the fall that was in heaven
was before the creation of
earth and so there was a plan already in
place
you know what i mean and and this is
like
you know sad to me that you would yeah
there's out there completely
disconnected they're not on the same
page
it's like nobody knows what's going on
they're just kind of like rolling the
dice to see what happens who can do it
the best way
if it doesn't work out i'm going to give
up it looks like god doesn't want to
save the human race it does look that
way
yeah so it's sad so anywhere there's
that frame
and you know he looks at jesus and he
says well
he looks at jesus dying on the cross and
he actually sees this as a weakness
right rather than the rest of the
angelic host would see this as this
absolute strength of god that he would
allow his son to even go down
there and and pay the penalty for
everyone else i mean that
that's the strength and the power of the
gospel right
right all right so i just want to go
through
these different episodes briefly with
you guys just so you can see
where they're going with their storyline
all right so here's the first one and it
says
god commands earth's mightiest superhero
sun star and sunstar is supposed to be
like a
superman type character it says
um to accept jesus as his roommate and
teach him how to use his power
in a more powerful way wait oh okay
yeah wait wait sunstar is accepting
jesus
so the idea is that
okay jesus has died on the cross right
okay now we're gonna send jesus
back to earth many years later like in
our present time
okay okay and god is just disappointed
with jesus like he's some kind of loser
he's failed he's failed
which is interesting because did god do
any better
no he really didn't right but he's he's
upset because it's
it's like jesus isn't holding up the
family name as this strong
powerful character you know he's weak he
needs to get his act together so
god is looking down on earth and he sees
this superhero
sun star who's like your superman type
and he's like okay
sunstar you need to take jesus as your
roommate
and teach him how to use his power in a
more powerful way
so much wrong with that dude especially
what really stands out to me is sun
star makes me just think of lucifer
right the bright
morning star and all this stuff and um
like he's going to teach jesus
you know the son is a representation of
satan when they worship the son
so god is saying jesus you need to look
towards satan and he's going to tell you
how to use your powers for
your benefit and all this stuff i didn't
highlight this part but it goes on it
says jesus
is shocked at the way humans have
twisted his message over to millennia
and vows to straighten them out you can
also hear
um you know when jesus was being tempted
by satan right he was tempting him to
use his power
he did not use his power for his own
self or whatever
you know what i mean he easily could
have and he did not
that would have been a sin right and so
he he basically said you know
of my own self i can do nothing that's
right i just want to clarify because i
know it'll come in the comments
i said that satan was the bright morning
star there's actually a reference to
that as being as jesus
and there's certain versions of the
bible that
call lucifer the same thing but in the
king james it's the
sun of the morning that's right but
either way the sun
he's what's he called sun star so i mean
yeah
the sun is a star and he is the you know
the one that's worshipped
as lucifer all right so what i'm going
to do with each of these descriptions is
i'm also
making a bigger version of the cover on
the screen so i'm just going to show you
guys anything that you want to comment
on feel free to jump in
you had a question it's kind of small i
can't tell that background bright
light what's a shape of i think that's
god the father in the background
okay and so if you can see here it's
sunstar and what is he doing he's
beating up this guy who's got a gun
and he's just like forcing communion
upon somebody or something like that
yeah he's feeding this criminal
right but it looks like by force right
it does kind of look like by force yeah
but the whole point is they have
completely different methods right one
is
oh i'm violent and the other one is
not violent so that background is a as a
silhouette of
the father i think so because it looks
like he's face palming
right right you know like what is he
doing he's trying to feed people you
know
like why can't he be more like sun star
all right so here's the second
issue and it says when a weirdo stalks
and threatens sunstar's girlfriend jesus
tries to prevent the superhero
from succumbing to rage but god has
other plans star flying through the air
and what is jesus doing writing on his
body
like scared holding on for dear life
like he's scared and
doesn't know what's going on he's losing
his sandal and
you know it looks like a superhero is
stronger than god
yeah it does it really does and and that
is kind of the point you know with with
god telling him you know you need to go
learn from this guy
on on how to get your act together
okay here's a third one so searching for
his missing grandmother
sunstar is forced to confront the
shortcomings of his superpowers
jesus left on his own for the day runs
afoul of
street preachers okay so it's going to
show you what some of those
street preachers look like
so he's the one that that is the reason
why the street teachers are out there
preaching or whatever it's like his
he's left alone so it's his fault that
they're all kind of springing up
no if you can actually look at this
closely all the street preachers
are these christians who are holding up
signs they're really angry
they're you know calling all these
sinners out and you can just tell like
they
it's like i mean it's trying to make him
i guess look more like
the westboro baptist crowd yeah you know
where they're just angry
god hates you he hates what you're doing
he looks like jesus and he's like oh no
and jesus is like
what like i can't believe like what are
they doing because
the context is you know he's coming back
to earth and he doesn't understand like
what happened to christianity yeah you
know which i don't disagree with that
i don't either i don't think that christ
really is looking down on people like
westboro baptist
and just saying like i can't believe you
guys are doing this like you're ruining
my name
taking the lord's name in vain is not
necessarily always just using his name
as a cuss word it's
proclaiming to be a christian and not
walking like one you're
you're proclaiming his name in vain and
yeah a true christian is not going to go
out there with a bunch of signs and say
you're all going to hell i mean that's
just not that's not the way christ
approached people it was all about
building friendship
and then telling them um
stories of the gospel you know this is
the way to live this is the alternative
but
you know just attack people yeah
for sure all right here's issue four
says jesus christ is missing sunstar
recruits a team of
lesser costumed heroes who resent his
great power
to assist him in the search for the son
of god
it's interesting here's this powerful
god and he can't find jesus
think about that can't find jesus all
right
and so here's the the cover for this
it shows jesus is in prison and then
there's
all these prisoners in there with him
and
you know one of them is trying to get
him to turn his lunch
and water into wine
or some better meal you know like fish
and bread
it looks like the the temptation uh in
the wilderness you know yeah
his power and everything yeah tempting
him to use his power for all these you
know
selfish demands as he's in prison and
he's there just kind of like
bored or frustrated or what have you
it's almost done in a mocking way you
know what i mean
but you know at the same time i kind of
go back to this as like
satire and it's like how many of us
you know do that to jesus you know
help my you know just make this quick
fix for my life that doesn't really have
anything to do
with christianity or with
my salvation or whatever yeah sometimes
i do like
hearing like christian comedians where
they kind of make fun of
christians as a whole how we kind of are
and
you know i it's just hard it's like
there's like this fine line you gotta
walk like
where do you draw the line when it comes
to making fun of
the bible or something like that you
know like i like i said i agree where
christ is getting frustrated with
christians doing things
the wrong way or whatever but yeah this
thing has definitely
went over the line a couple times yeah i
think the point he's trying to make with
at least with this you know this scene
is god's not a
genie that you rubbed the lamp and
you're like okay make three wishes now
you know whatever you want you want to
be rich you want to be whatever
it's not like that yeah which i think is
is
you know a good point so here's the
fifth episode
it says god and satan get coffee
sunstar receives a tempting offer from a
brutal dictator and jesus
shares some sad secret memories with his
flock
and so here is the the cover
where god and satan are uh getting
coffee although it looks like satan has
a martini and
god is drinking wine he's got a
stick looks like moses or something yeah
i don't know that he has a stick but you
can see you know
it's kind of interesting if you look at
this like god is dressed
almost like he's this hobo yeah you know
caveman and you know of course he's
grumpy and angry
and satan there is there no satan has
the nicer clothes
his his hair is made up into like horns
and the purple and scarlet yeah he's
wearing the purple and scarlet
you know and he's he doesn't look his
anger and he's just you know here they
are just
kind of staring each other down
so that was the fifth episode episode
six
the last one in this series it says
sunstar and sheila
i think that's his girlfriend leave
jesus in charge as they go off on their
honeymoon
and then it says satan tempts jesus one
last time
so it seems like satan is the boss of
jesus
or what i don't know if they're getting
with that
um but you know it's like why i
i do question like well why does jesus
need to be tempted again
you know he already proved everything he
already overcame
so here's the last graphic and it's it's
jesus
with his um his arm around sunstar
almost like he's holding him
up and this guy has some something
around his neck
i'm not sure what it is like chains and
rocks and there's all these vegetables
and i'm not sure what's what's with the
vegetables but
um it's just interesting that you know
when jesus comes back in this comic it
seems like
uh all mark is getting that is he's
disappointed in what christian has
become
and he needs to reboot his image which
is a bit of truth in that
it's true but it it seems like that's
the
end of it yeah and so that's not really
picture of the second coming yeah right
jesus isn't coming back to
reboot his image or give christianity a
like uh you know okay you guys didn't do
it right the first time let's let's do
it again
or like a makeover yeah right his second
coming is
final like it's done things are decided
at that point you know what i mean
yeah i mean if christianity didn't get
it right the first time
yeah what else what else is there he's
like i've given you guys so much time
i've given you all the resources
i sent my spirit you know what else
does he need to do but anyway
what is this guy getting at right what i
want to get into is like
mark's thinking is this just a joke does
he think it's funny
why do this right and it really goes
back to satire and i
and and really perspective if you think
about it so here's from
um uh comic book reports as mark russell
explains
second coming's approach to jesus christ
he says
i think religious fundamentalists and
critics who are trying to stop
second coming aren't interested in
protecting christ
so much as their ability to control his
narrative
he said mega churches fox news
pundits and youtube outrage merchants
see christianity as their product
and view anyone else talking about
christ
as a form of copyright infringement
they probably correctly suspect that
it's
not christ who's being parodied but
themselves
and how they've twisted his teachings of
mercy for the powerless
into a self-serving tool of the powerful
so it's really a mockery of christians
it sounds like
because some of the things he said
didn't sound disrespectful to
christ in this little piece that you
just read
yeah his observation is jesus is being
used by other people who call themselves
christian to accomplish their own agenda
i'm confused when so many people think
that that's their reason for not
becoming a christian it's all about
money
how i mean there are you know the
kenneth copeland's and all that there
are those people that
fly around in jets and they're preachers
but the majority
of christianity is not like that i'll
say that the majority of christians are
probably not rich and probably
more others focused they give to
charities and things like this
even even um preachers that are in third
world countries
african preachers i mean they have 15
churches
yeah one guy you know what i mean and
it's like here we have
okay yeah one pastor part of your church
or whatever like this but there are some
churches even in the u.s
where i know that these preachers are
just
running around in circles preaching at
all these different churches and they're
literally barely paid you know what i
mean and it's like
they they they are giving so much of
their lives to
this work uh but yeah like you said
there's a few
i think that small percent of prosperity
gospel is a
weak point to go against christians i
would agree
but if you think about it it's a loud
voice
right yeah they're the ones that get a
tv time mega churches
fox news youtube i mean these are things
that are in
people's faces and if that's what you're
consuming that's going to be your view
of
christianity right and so
you know being a loud voice there's a
lot of things in this world that are
loud
voices and they're good at creating
stereotypes
the same thing that you said about
christians is probably true for people
of other faiths like
the majority of muslims are probably not
the type of people they're going to
strap
bombs to themselves and go and blow
something up
it's just not like that's what you see a
lot in movies and stuff yeah but that's
what gets put
in front of your face and so yeah we got
to be careful about
stereotyping which i think yeah
you make a good point that's that's
happening a little bit here this is not
all of christianity but
it is a loud voice and um
there are people who do do this i mean
if we're fair yeah
yes this happens here in the new york
post he
really does a lot more reflection and so
i'm going to go through these uh with
you guys there are several quotes here
but before i do that before i blow this
up i want to ask you guys
what is the gospel to you message of
hope
okay message of hope god's yeah
plan of salvation to redeem us from this
fallen state that we can't really help
ourselves get out of we need his
strength to
to have salvation okay
i believe that it's god's offering of us
to have a chance to
to to be part of his kingdom i mean what
a beautiful
beautiful thing when we so don't deserve
it why would he waste his time with us
you know yet he does yeah it's a great
gift to humanity
right so we're going to get into a
little bit of how
how he sees this he said headlines aside
if you read the book
what you actually find is not a takedown
of religion
but as russell describes it an attempt
to spread
the gospel really wow that's shocking
that's surprising i think with anything
it what are you walking away with it
that's kind of what i always think of
like people always go ah whatever you
guys just
see what you see you know and it's like
okay
yes you know sometimes there are things
that can be
on the line of like you know we don't
quite know so
we're making an educated guess but but i
don't see how people are walking away
with a
better understanding of how loving god
is or
how jesus gave everything for us no
christian is going to buy this which
he's you're not trying to convert
i mean maybe he's trying to convert
certain types of christians but no
christian is going to buy this
so it's probably going to be atheists
and agnostics and stuff and yeah you're
right i don't think they're reading that
i think they're reading it and laughing
at
god getting drunk and you know the way
that god is portrayed they're not going
to walk away like wow
maybe christianity is true you know yeah
i don't see that
i guess my question in going through all
this is what does the gospel look like
to him
you know if he says it's his attempt to
spread the gospel what does the gospel
look like
to mark russell and i think he's trying
to get people to think about what jesus
really came to do
which i think is noble but
the way he's doing it i don't think he's
quite accomplishing the goal well maybe
he is that he wants
but i just want you to see like out of
his own words like
how this shapes up so superhero comics
suggests that physical violence
is the solution to any problem whereas i
wanted a comic that meditated
on the nature of power itself and
suggests that there might be other
solutions that don't involve
drop kicking i mean it makes sense right
um there is a lot of physical violence
in
superhero comics in fact i would say
that's
yeah it's a good observation that's how
they pretty much solve all their
problems
right you've gotta be more powerful than
somebody else
he says he was raised pentecostal but he
says he no longer subscribes to
organized religion
he does hope that readers will discover
a jesus that's faithful
to the new testament i'm a little
confused at that
based on what you've shown um i i i
would be very
curious to see what parts he thinks
is illustrating that all right we're
leading up to something so we're gonna
we're gonna get there
okay so he says there are a lot of
things that christ said that i think are
fantastic
and his mission was radical and
brilliant russell says
but christ's message the writer says has
been
hijacked okay somehow christianity has
become a tool of the empires
that it was originally designed to help
people escape
here is where i start to disagree
and take a different direction with him
he says jesus was the original rebel
an enemy of the powerful preaching
against two things that empires use to
subjugate their citizens
greed and fear what do you disagree with
the reason i disagree with that is i
don't think
jesus was a rebel i think that is
the that is how you would characterize
satan
satan was the rebel
he was the original rebel if you want to
you know use his term
so satan was the original rebel not
jesus
and i don't think his objective was to
preach against
greed and fear only
that wasn't his earthly mission his
earthly mission was that jesus came to
save us from sin
amen and that is the gospel yeah
repentance and remission of sin i mean
that's what john
was you know preaching in the wilderness
and and that was part of jesus's mission
said well as well
so if you're just freeing people from
greed and fear
is that like the end-all no you know i
mean
to me there's way more to jesus's
mission than just
freeing people from greed and fear he
doesn't free us to just say okay now
live your lives however you want because
there's no more greed there's no more
fear
yeah i wouldn't call jesus a rebel
maybe a revolutionary i don't know if if
that's a bad term i never really looked
at the definition of a revolutionary but
i
i think the understanding of
christianity
and or god because christianity hadn't
been really born yet right
um was so darkened that you've got a
pure person that comes along that does
it right
and it seems so foreign to everyone else
i think that's the world
i think that's what it was it wasn't
that he was just going against the grain
for the sake of going against the grain
he was the correct representation and
everybody is sickened with this like
direction of life that they're gone you
know if we if we use the scriptures
it says that rebellion is the sin of
witchcraft and we know that jesus didn't
sin so
if you're gonna use term for term i
wouldn't call jesus a ribble a rebel
just
because of those two things because
satan was the original rebel and bible
says
you know rebellion is a sin of
witchcraft so anyway i want to read this
verse from
galatians 1 6-7 as we're kind of
wrapping things up he says
this is paul talking to the galatian
church he says i'm marvel that you are
turning away so soon
from him who called you in the grace of
christ
to a different gospel this is not a new
thing like people have dealt with
different versions of the gospel for
a long time as far back as paul's day
and he says which is not another so
people call it
the gospel but it's really not it's
really not the gospel
and he says but there are some who
trouble you and want to pervert
the gospel of christ and so i think in
our day and age
you know we also have to be cautious
about perverting the gospel
of christ and it's really not that hard
i mean
it's a very simple message jesus died
to save us from sin you don't have to
complicate it beyond that you know or
turn it into
something else and so
if your picture is not a picture of
love and self-sacrifice then i think
that's going to
drive you away from god you know
and i think that happened i'm going to
guess i don't know i haven't talked to
him i think that happened in mark
russell's case you know he's not
he didn't see growing up in his home a
picture of love and self-sacrifice
because that causes people to reject god
and i think that we should give people
at least
a little bit of intellectual credit for
that
yeah you know it makes sense when people
reject god if they don't see the proper
picture
of god all right now i'm going to go out
and eliminate him and i get it
i'm going to go out on limb here because
i believe that
you know we need to do a better call a
better job
at representing christ right
this this is a classic case here of of
how easily somebody can maybe have
something that went bad in their life
maybe a
you know a a youth youth pastor
you know outstated him and made him feel
like not welcome or something like this
and then all of a sudden it's like you
you're like well i don't i don't want
anything else to do with organized
religion
i mean people should be generally if you
are a true follower of christ they
should be generally like
i want you as my neighbor like i really
like being around you
i feel like this person is a really
amazing person even if i don't share
your same ideals
if you are a true christian that love
should be pouring out of you and how can
people reject that right isn't that what
the world's all about love love love
everybody wants love right
but that's that's what a christian
really should feel so i i feel
saddened that he walked away from from
christianity with that kind of an
idea of organized religion and and all
too often it's too much that case but
in all of our little small circles we
can do better at
at being that representation so to those
who are watching if you don't have
that picture of god that picture that is
of love and self
sacrifice what if you're wrong
and i believe you are what if you're
wrong and god
really is a god of love what are you
missing out on
right i want to let you think about that
what is your picture of god i would like
to invite the viewers those that are
watching to
comment below and tell us what is your
picture of god share that with us
we want to know is it a positive picture
is it a negative picture
is your picture of god affected by
something that happened to your life
like scotty was just saying
whatever that is we'd like to hear about
it and we'd also like to encourage you
to
revisit that picture and see if you can
discover a picture of god
that is really beautiful and i think you
can find that in the gospels if you read
the story of jesus and you read about
what he did for people and how he put
his life on the line to save you
from the sin in this world i think
you'll see a beautiful picture of god
and that is
the true picture so that's all i got
make sure you guys like comment
subscribe
and uh we will see you again on the next
show
thanks for watching this has been led
live catch you later
[Music]
you